bienvenue dans le débat politique
il y a quinze ans jour pour jour le 29
mai 2005 55 % des français voté non au
traité constitutionnel européen à quatre
ans plus tard le traité de lisbonne
était adoptée sans tenir compte de la
voix du peuple
cette date du 29 mai 2005 marque telle
une rupture entre bruxelles et les
peuples européens peut-on parler de
démocratie à l'échelon de l'europe
une question qui se pose alors de cette
crise sanitaire et pour en débattre ce
soir nous sommes donc avec georges
kuzmanovic fondateur de république
souveraine bonsoir georges kuzmanovic
nous sommes également avec patrick
mennucci ancien député du parti
socialiste et conseiller municipal à
marseille bonsoir patrick mennucci merci
à tous les deux d'être sur rt france on
va écouter d'abord le président jacques
chirac à l'époque de ce nom majoritaire
à la constitution européenne et pour lui
c'était plutôt un choc politique écouter
la france c'est démocratiquement
exprimée vous avez majoritairement
rejeté la constitution européenne et
j'en prends acte et voilà pour la
déclaration de jacques chirac c'est
votre décision souveraine avait dit
alors jacques chirac on a vu après que
ce n'était pas forcément le cas
patrick mennucci est ce que les français
finalement avec ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui est ce que les français
n'avaient pas raison à l'époque de
défendre cette souveraineté alors
souveraineté nationale je suis un peu
gêné de vous répondre à ces petits tubes
parce que
la rate là le fait que le traité n'est
pas pour ratifier a fait que sa forme
d'éléments qui était malgré tout
beaucoup se retrouver dans le traité de
lisbonne ont été supprimés et c'est vrai
que aujourd'hui quand on regarde ce qui
se passe avec la crise sanitaire
peut-être que la réaction des français
ne sera plus la même après la façon dont
l'europe aufauvre réagi réagi assez
positivement à la situation économique
en tout cas pratiques dans laquelle nous
sommes donc je suis j'ai voté non au
traité donc je comprends parfaitement la
poésie des positions de ceux qui ont
voté longue j'en étais au sein du port
socialiste beaucoup de dirigeants de
militants et d'élus ont voté non mais je
ne suis pas persuadé avec le recul que
nous avons eues à ce moment là nous
avons eu raison de rejeter la
constitution mais simplement le fait de
rejeter la position et de créer cette
espèce de bruit de fond qui est que la
souveraineté du peuple a été trahie et
ensuite par le traité lisbonne et puis
pas des ratifications de 2012 nous
paraissent un moyenne pour les européens
on a un énorme avec nous ce soir avec
les gens là qui ça permet de continuer à
expliquer ce que je pense c'est une
erreur c'est à dire que nos dirigeants
sont toujours en responsabilité au
travers de l'europe et que quelque chose
va pas c'est la faute à rouen - je pense
que le couloir implantée à des
responsabilités propres et qu' il vaut
mieux s'en prendre aux dirigeants
français
car william définitive que moyen de ce
qu'on en crée alors là vous dites ce qui
ne va pas on accuse souvent le rock là
c'est carrément l'inefficacité de
l'europe pour gérer cette crise
salutaire puisqu'elle était absente en
tout cas dans les premiers temps il
s'agit pas de lui porter évidemment la
responsabilité de cette crise sanitaire
une question à georges kuzmanovic vous
avez cosigné une tribune aujourd'hui
dans
journal marianne qui s'appelle liberté
j'écris ton nom l eau n bien sûr et vous
dit ce jour là peut-être les français
posent et il la première pierre du monde
d'après c'est à dire bon d'abord je fais
partie de ceux des je pense de très
nombreux français qui considèrent que le
29 mai 2005 a été un grand moment de
démocratie et un grand moment de
souveraineté populaire c'est-à-dire de
d'accession du peuple à la politique
pour il faut rappeler ce qui s'est passé
cette époque là on avait l'ensemble de
l'appareil médiatique et politique
95 % qui appelait à voter oui en
prédisant que si le nom ont été votés la
france est frappée ddip l'egypte et ce
serait une catastrophe
certains parlaient même de guerre bon le
peuple c'est à voter démocratiquement
je tiens à rappeler à patrice que quand
même à chaque fois que les peuples
européens ont été appelés à voter par
référendum sur telle ou telle
disposition de l'union européenne
ils ont toujours voté contre il doit
bien y avoir une raison et nous sommes
en démocratie
en tout état de cause peut-être que le
peuple avait mal voté selon vous je ne
le pense pas je pense qu'ils avaient été
très très lucide sur ce qui était en
train de se passer
il a voté non mais les élites politiques
se sont effectivement réuni ensuite en
conclave gauche droite de gouvernement à
versailles et en 2008 ont ratifié un
traité de lisbonne qui contrairement à
ce que vous dites est la copie conforme
du traité constitutionnel européen
puisque c'est ce qu'en disait monsieur
valéry giscard d'estaing qui avait été
rédacteur du traité constitutionnel
européen
pas parce que vous dites sur la crise
actuelle moi je regarde du côté des
italiens et de leurs représentants le
premier c'est-à-dire le premier ministre
monsieur giuseppe konté qui est un grand
européen comme andy qui croient à
l'union européenne qui défendent l
europe n est bien il a dit on s'en
souviendra de l'attitude de l'union
européenne on s'en souviendra
du rôle qu'elle joue européenne et de
faire des sanctions en pleine crise
sanitaire très gras avec des milliers
d'italiens qui mouraient que l'union
européenne fasse des sanctions sauf
qu'il en attend beaucoup maintenant
d'union européenne pour avoir justement
un peu de finance de la part de du plan
de relance de l'union européenne oui
mais là c'est ce sont deux choses sont
des choses très différentes
actuellement tous les néo libéraux quel
qu'il soit qu'il soit au niveau européen
à la commission open ou en france avec
monsieur emmanuel macron n'ont pas le
choix ils sont en train de se prendre
les mieux placés en face nous sommes
dans une situation de crise grave à
laquelle nous a emmené le monde d'avant
dont monsieur macro est l'incarnation et
le monde d'avancé un monde où tout est
décidé par les marchés par la loi par la
main visible et de libre échange absolu
total on voit bien où est ce que ça nous
mène
et ils n'ont pas le choix nous sommes
face à une crise économique qui va être
bien plus grave que la crise qu'est la
crise sanitaire
vous voyez ce qui s'est passé à arnaud
aujourd'hui les annonces faites par
renault malgré la visite dans le nord du
président de la république
une annonce de 4600 suppressions
d'emplois fermés recul de la fermeture
d'un site
il va y avoir beaucoup de chômeurs il va
encore plus de précaires et si ces gens
là ne veulent pas avoir une révolte
populaire qui déjà existé avant on se
rappelle les gg quand c'est leur affaire
et il est simple de deux de ces
suppressions d'emplois mais et l'europe
est responsable du fait que l à l a
poussé à l'extrême le monde néolibéral
l'économie néolibérale
elle a poussé à l'extrême la
l'affaiblissement des services publics
si nous avons un hôpital qui est
déficient c'est parce qu'il fallait
respecter des règles imbéciles qui nous
contraignent contrairement à ce que vous
disiez mennucci il me semble qu'il y a
des nous avons perdu la souveraineté
monétaire nous avons perdu la
souveraineté budgétaire nous n'avons pas
réellement de souveraineté géopolitique
et l'europe
contraint par des règles de financière à
ce que nous limitions nos
investissements dans les services
publics on voit combien ça nous coûte
dans tous les services publics les
écoles est la police l'armée et surtout
l'hôpital maintenant c'est flagrant
il y avait quand même
un an de grève un an manifestation avant
et qui faisait écho à des des mouvements
et des grèves avant mais pendant un an
avant cette crise il ya eu des
manifestations et des grèves de médecins
qui disait on n'a plus les moyens pour
soigner nos concitoyens je vois les
effets et ça c'est la cause c'est la
faute de ces réellement la fois de
l'union européenne et de la position de
politiques d'austérité
on va reparler de ce qui s'est passé en
2005 les médias ont été accusés les
médias classiques ont été accusés de
trop vouloir finalement penché vers le
oui de ne pas être suffisamment
explicatifs sur ce traité patrick
mennucci est-ce que vous pensez que les
médias ont fait correctement leur
travail ont-ils été partisan d'ailleurs
les titres aujourd'hui ne font pas
beaucoup en tout cas cet anniversaire
n'aimait pas beaucoup mentionné dans la
presse pourquoi
écoutez moi je j'ai une lecture un peu
plus il ya un peu plus politique
mdrr que celle que l'on vient d'entendre
de la part de jean jé cuban reach
n'oublions pas que des sondages ont été
faits après le vote non pour savoir
pourquoi les gens avaient voté non et je
les ai retrouvés avant votre émission
cinquante deux pour cent de ceux qui ont
voté non disent qu'ils ont voté contre
nicolas sarkozy
ça c'est la première acte et il n'est
pas la question d'europe
ils ont voté contre nicolas sarkozy et
on retrouve d'ailleurs c'est pourquoi on
à 55% des électeurs du parti socialiste
qui alors que les dirigeants comme
françois hollande appelait à voter oui
ont voté non donc et ensuite on a 40 %
de jeunes qui disent qu'ils ont voté en
réseau 2,2 des conditions du du traité
fait de la constitution européenne
donc je pense qu'il faut être prudent et
georges et viennent d'être l'incarnation
de ce que je disais dans ma première
intervention
c'est à dire est qu'il fait partie de
ceux qui considèrent que ce que font nos
dirigeants singulièrement en ce moment
monsieur mâcon est lié à des décisions
concernent conspirationnistes occulte je
n'en sais rien de la commission
européenne mais en fait ce n'est pas la
commission européenne qui dit à la
france de payer ces infirmières 30% en
dessous des soignants à ce niveau en
allemagne ce n'est pas la commission
européenne qui dit à la france de passer
une grande partie de son budget de
service public dans l'armée par exemple
je ne suis pas content que nous ayons
une très bonne armée mais ce n'est pas
l'union européenne et qui dit de le
faire donc il faut arrêter
l'union européenne a des responsabilités
mais ceux qui comme nous venons de
l'entendre et c'est souvent le cas des
anti européens explique que c'est
l'europe qui de toute façon à toutes les
responsabilités
mettre les dirigeants quels qu'ils
soient et particulièrement monsieur mac
pro en ce moment dans une situation qui
est plutôt confortable parce que ce
n'est pas eux qui prennent les décisions
mais c'est l'union européenne mais c'est
un très mauvais service que nos armes
nos rangs la france c'est un très
mauvais service que nous ramenons à ce
pays parce que c'est une protection pour
ceux qui veulent continuer le nez au lit
le libéralisme appelons le par son nom
que d'expliquer que ce n'est pas leur
faute mais qui sonne juste les
stipendiés houle et les représentants de
d'une europe qui est absolument horrible
je ne le crois pas et je pense que
l'europe a plein de défauts je les ai
souligné moi même je vous ai dit que
j'ai voté non au référendum
mais quand je vois qu'elle mai 1850
milliards sur la table pour se relever
de la crise du coc vide
je me demande qui serait capable de le
faire et quant à la souveraineté
monétaire qui est évoqué tout à l'heure
il
ce serait intéressant de voir ce que
serait devenu le franc avec la situation
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui dans
l'europe est un moyen aujourd'hui de
nous relever de la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes
alors entre temps il ya eu aussi le
nombre existe avec une monnaie qui est
propre à la grande bretagne est ce qu'il
est ce qu'il ya une rupture en 2005
georges kiejman au beach une rupture
entre justement c est dit à bruxelles
que les personnes finalement ont du mal
à aaa même a cité ces personnes
incarne-t-elle vraiment le le pouvoir
politique européen
y at il eu une rupture entre ses élites
et les peuples des nations européennes
mais bien évidemment s'est incarnée par
ce qu'en disait le précédent président
de la commission européenne monsieur
jean claude juncker qui est dit il ne
peut pas y avoir de démocratie contre le
traité européen et l'union européenne
l'a montré à chaque fois à chaque fois
qu'il y avait un référendum
et je rappelle quand même que l'article
3 de la constitution française stipule
que la souveraineté du peuple et
s'exprime par l'élection de ses
représentants des députés comme a été
monsieur mennucci ou par voie
référendaire encore une fois à chaque
fois que ce soit en irlande deux fois
aux pays-bas
que ce soit en france en 2005 en grèce
en 2015 en italie en 2011
faut-il encore en citer les ont voté
contre cette union européenne alors soit
on considère que ce sont tous des gens
imbéciles qui ne comprennent rien et qu'
ils sont parfaitement les tous
anti-européen et là je souhaite dire
monsieur nous tient au fait de la
rhétorique
c'est inadmissible vous parler à chaque
fois que vous dites nous sommes contre
l'europe mais nous sommes contre l'union
européenne l'union européenne est une
institution spécifique avec des règles
spécifiques de fonctionnement et c'est
cela qui sont combattus les français qui
ont voté non à raison en 2005 n'ont pas
voté parce qu'il voulait se renfermer
dans un nationalisme imbéciles dans les
frontières françaises
ils s'opposaient à cette union
européenne là c'est très important
encore une fois s'est ému en pena qui
est entièrement dédiée à l'intérêt des
institutions financières et quand on est
intérêt on va beaucoup me georges
kiejman avait pas ce que j'aurais qu'on
écoute quand même jean claude juncker
c'était en 2015 il parlait justement de
la démocratie en europe et pour lui il
ne peut y avoir de choix démocratique
contre les traités européens écouter le
sexe c'est lui-même qui l'a vous dire
que tout va changer parce qu'il ya un
nouveau gouvernement à athènes
c'est prendre ses désirs pour des
réalités il ne peut pas y avoir de choix
démocratique contre les traités
européens
c'est une pure spéculation le débat sur
la sortie de la grèce de la monnaie
commune est un faux débat
patrick mennucci c'est clair il ne peut
pas y avoir de débat démocratique contre
les traités européens ont alors on ne
peut pas critiquer je ne prends pas pour
moi ce que dit le problème le problème
et et moi je comprends parfaitement que
l'on puisse préférer l'isolément qu'on
puisse vouloir que notre monnaie sous
sol frange le rappelle aujourd'hui dans
la situation où nous sommes
j'aimerais bien savoir où on sort et le
franc non mais c'est pas là juste milieu
là il s'agit pas d'en rester peut-on
réformer l'europe peut-on le large pour
me c'est la question que se pose
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
magali c'est ce que j'allais dire mieux
vaut changer l'europe de l'intérieur que
de jouer avec les crises et les peurs de
l'europe et nous les sociaux démocrates
nous avons toujours été en faveur de
l'europe mais pas de l'europe qui est
celle que nous voyons aujourd'hui à
bruxelles mais est ce que ça veut dire
que pour cela les dirigeants français de
droite ou d'extrême droite ferait mieux
que ce que font ceux qui se contentent
on prétend qu'ils sont trop aux ordres
de l'europe
je rappelle quand même que on revient
sur le vote des tesnières 15 ans quand
même ce sont les partis populistes qui
aujourd'hui au ces ce qu' ils sont
devenus 15 ans après donc 95% des
votants des ddd des jeunes qui se
reconnaissent en beauté normal le front
national
le rpf à l'époque de monsieur charles
pasqua peut-être duquel vous vous
reconnaissez aujourd'hui proche
le mpf de monsieur de villiers et
l'extrême gauche c'est ça qui a été la
base des 55 % pour le reste il y avait
une division sérieuse dans les partis de
droite et de gauche de gouvernement
mais moi je crois que la crise que nous
venons de de traverser dans laquelle
nous sommes encore évidemment même si on
sent que les choses vont mieux à
l'europe
et bien c'est sans doute le moment de
regarder comment cette union européenne
peut s'améliorer
en tout cas il ya un besoin qui est très
important c'est que si dans l'année qui
vient il y à un redressement économique
sérieux l'étonnant de l'union européenne
pour me dire que les 1850 milliards qui
sont mis dans les économies nationales
n'y auront pas été courir
j'ai changé je réponds si nous reste
deux minutes par nous tous les deux en
même temps est-ce que c'est qu'on en
crée une forme de 100 milliards sur le
chômage par exemple comment on aurait
fait pour le financer réponse sans
réponse sur ce qu'ils mènent avec
raiponce georges kuzmanovic on vous
écoute donc a priori un ca y est georges
kuzmanovic est ce que vous êtes en
mesure de sécurité ne viennent pas de
l'union européenne ils viennent pas de
la poche des de la commission européenne
qui viennent des états et en partie la
france qui je vous le rappelle
amusez-vous le semble et d'oublier la
france est bénéfique et et contributeur
net à cette union européenne on donne de
l'argent à morsang de l'union européenne
c'est pas le européenne qui vient en
aide à la france mais ce que vous dites
c'est une politique d'impuissance qui a
toujours caractérisé le port qui
socialisent je vous rappelle que mal
heureusement le traité de lisbonne qui a
été là un déni démocratique contre le
vote référence du match du peuple
français contre lors du référendum sur
le tc eux inscrit dans le marbre une
politique néolibérale qui ne peut pas
être changé c'est un mensonge
il faut pour qui le moindre changement
d'une virgule l'accord de 28 à 27
maintenant vous savez parfaitement que
c'est impossible et c'est pour ça que
monsieur juncker à juste raison disait
il ne peut pas y avoir de vote
démocratique car il ne peut pas y avoir
de changement et c'est là le drame
est ce que vous avez dit parfaitement
honteux contre vos camarades de gauche
retournent aux camarades de gauche
je vous rappelle que le parti communiste
français a fait une campagne
extraordinaire attaque avait fait une
campagne extraordinaire des militants
socialistes jean luc mélenchon avec une
campagne extraordinaire
et dire que ce ne sont que des
nationalités pourrait amener non
monsieur mélenchon étaient étaient
contre ont été été pour le monde mais si
vous avez si vous l'avez insinué que ça
qu'est ce que le fn les affaires et non
attendez je vous répondrai donc le
problème principal
le problème principal c'est que le
peuple avait compris qu'on ne pouvait
pas mettre dans le marbre une politique
économique on doit le match que ce matin
je suis désolé je suis désolé vous
interrompre mais on n'a plus le temps je
vous laisse trois secondes patrick
mennucci parce que je vois que vous
voulez réagir mais vraiment 3 secondes
et donc je veux pas te le jure je dis ça
je dis pas que je ne mets pas en cause
le parti du risque de méningiome peuple
entier moi même voté non je dis que dans
la structuration de l'île électorat
voilà il y avait 52 % de jeunes qui
voulaient s'opposer à sarkozy
et quand on regarde le front national le
mpf et le rpf de l'époque de charme à ce
mois on continuera ses lecteurs on fera
les parties de on fera une saison 2 à ce
débat qui suscite évidemment beaucoup de
réactions c'est la fin malheureusement
de ce face à face
merci beaucoup georges kuzmanovic et
merci à vous patrick mennucci d'avoir
participé à ce débat politique
[Musique]